I've said this to women all the time you  have to take some responsibility for the  fact that you can't control outside  situations you can't control if a guy is  walking down the street who seeks to do  harm to you you can't control any of  that all you can control is what you put  out there so you have to not that you're  going to be responsible for somebody  else's bad behavior toward you but you  have to make smart decisions and I  always I love this because it's like  again these liberals infantilize women  they infantilize them it's like don't  worry honey do whatever you want walk  down the street naked if somebody comes  at you like it's nonsense no the message  to women should be just be aware of  what's really going on right there are  dangers out there